gelée je lis c'est une catastrophe ait
fait une catastrophe que vous arrive là
c'était souvent cette jolie
l'épouvantable annonce un facteur vous
perdez la tête des enfants jeunes et
médias révélaient que je lis remplissez
ma sacoche de petits gâteaux dépliant
oui oui 6 non non non non ça surtout le
pas avoir faim non mais allez-y alesi
m'étais encore julie allez allez allez
c'est à vous que je ne comprends pas à
la baie vous n'avez plus métiers des
bonbons a les mêmes idées pour un beau
fond mais tout le bocage julie aller
vite
ils sont à stoney vous rendre la monnaie
plus tard l'espace la chose la plus
catastrophique de lille oui
vous allez les effrayer oui ben oui non
mais où vous savez il ne risque rien
nous genre la chance parce que vous
allez me dire une fois pour toutes ce
qu'il se passe elle se passe
au nord je suis je voudrais bien vous le
dire mais je ne peux pas juger trop mal
au coeur alors que je m'engage
je vous expliquerai après surtout ne pas
avoir faim parce qu
au revoir
quel mystère mais de quoi peut-il bien
s'agir donc mal oh que je suis malade
oh ma chère amie sommet mois
de m'embaucher mais j'imagine que vous
avez mal au coeur comme le facteur exact
j'ai famille besoin d'être classé
s'avérer très profitable
matheson le gam mon coeur danse le tango
dans poitrine mais que se passe-t-il
vous ne savez pas et non
jérémy ne vous a rien dit rien n'a pas
eu tant il est parti se coucher à
asseyez vous serrer mes chers amis je
vous explique
je vous écoute casimir
je pourrais pas j'ai trop à gauche
quels souvenirs
organisé un concours de zouk route à
nouveau je crois que vous avez assisté
au dernier pour cours des soucoupes
qu'il avait organisée je me souviens en
effet cette rhétorique il ajouté alors
nous coûte la création tv de la
confiture d'abricots des cas où des
choix
répétés de moi j'ai arrêté la set list
mais monsieur du staff et intervenir les
pouces vous opposer à cette décision
vous êtes président de l'île aux enfants
je sais je sais mais faut réagir il faut
interdire ce concours de choucroute je
ne peux pas mais pourquoi est-ce que je
suis malade que je veux juste pas
beaucoup
les enfants vous allez me dire à quel
point de la carte correspond la ville de
paris
paris ici très bien la ville de lille
tout en haut c'est parfait la ville de
nantes
se trouve ici bordeaux
bordeaux ici oui toulouse
toulouse juste en dessous parfait
clermont ferrand clermont ferrand lyon
c'est toujours très bien grenoble kroll
à bessines nice la russe et la ville de
marseille
formidable les enfants vous êtes de plus
en plus fort il ya toujours et plus rien
à vous apprendre tenue pour vous
récompenser jeunes à faire à chacun et
bonbons chez julie voulait bien
alors suivez moi ça alors c'est curieux
le kiosque de julie est entièrement
fermé rien ça m'avait rien dit d'écouter
jeu louvre pour vous les enfin
cette julie toujours la même mais
changera jamais servez vous et pendant
ce temps là je met l'argent dans le
tiroir caisse de julie voilà tout le
monde et servir
mais moi il ne me reste plus qu'à
m'occuper en même temps et du meba l'eau
et de kiosques de julie
voilà j'espère qu'il ne va pas tarder à
revenir parce que
qu'est le reste il l'a déjà sita
c'est curieux quand même qu'il ait
quitté le jardin sont sans rien dire à
personne à moins que à moins qu'il ne
lui soit arrivé quelque chose
allô allô dinars oui c'est françois est
très important léonard aurais tu vu
julie aujourd'hui non
que je passe te voir chez casimir non
non écouter c'est impossible et au nar
je viens de te dire que julie a disparu
je suis tout seul pour m'occuper des
enfants et de tous
léonard léonard je te répète qu'il m'est
impossible de venir te voir
il raccroche
[Musique]
quel plaisir de venir dans ce paysage je
suis bien contente de voir casimir mais
moi aussi je suis ravi de te voir
casimir qu'ils ignorent que tu n'aurais
pas vu julie aujourd'hui un joli nom non
pourquoi julie a disparu elle connaîtra
la plage ce n'est pas grave mais moi
j'ai eu une nouvelle formidable annoncé
ça m'ennuie tout de même oui oui oui je
sais bien que julie est maladroite qu'il
n'a pas toujours la tête sur ses deux
épaules mais tout de même
françois tu ne m'écoute pas
si si si si je t'écoute alors dû à une
nouvelle extraordinaire un point
extraordinaire jeu vient d'organiser un
nouveau concours de choucroute à la
cellulite ou
tu peux répéter ce que tu viens de me
dire là tout de suite tu as parfaitement
entendu un concours de choucroute oui et
tu seras le candidat numéro ne tient pas
en prendre aussi en eau gaz signés non
c'est pas possible pas de courir en soi
mais ça c'est possible le la choucroute
et déjà a déjà cuites 2015 signé par
pitié tu vas pas nous faire ça d'un coup
tu maintenant c'est trop tard le
concours commence dans une demi heure
assez mûrs tu aurais pu m'en parler un
vent j'ai envoyé le facteur et monsieur
lui ce noble pour revenir
mais je comprends tout maintenant oui
parle pas trop tous les minots mais je
veux dire que je comprends pourquoi
julie a disparu tout à l'heure j'ai vu
monsieur du snob et le facteur qui passe
en vitesse et puis le léonard avait une
nouvelle importante à un communiqué
léonard justement c'est lui qui m'en a
donné l'idée à ben le pauvre ça se voit
qu'il n'a pas connu le le dernier
concours de choucroute non mais il est
là lui dans mes mémoires oui alors je
suppose que pour améliorer sa choucroute
du ajoute de dante et des fraises un dj
sucre en poudre du pouvoir des départs
nation et de la chantilly et des
morceaux de chambre
9 on nous met enfin en jeu j'en ai déjà
les l'eau à la bouche - tessi miracle
casimir arrête toile ce nom ne sais quoi
qu'est synergies faut que je vais me
coucher c'est toi je
sois mais non non non non oh là là mais
alors quel fragilité
il manque encore un peu de sel
voilà qu'elle en
course à longchamp mauvais
très bien enfin je ne comprends pas ils
devraient déjà tous être là pour le
concours
commence à comprendre leur absence est
ce que tu veux dire qu'ils ne
reviendront pas quoi je n'y comprends
très bien
qu'un long terme épouvantable enfin je
ne vais pas pouvoir manger cette souche
regroupe tout ça là
je n'ai plus faim mais au fait c'est toi
qui m'ont a donné l'idée
pardon tu tu m'as demandé où j'en étais
de ton livre de mémoires ce n'est pas ma
faute à moi si je lisais justement
laventure du concours du plus grand
mangeur de choucroute oui on écoute ne
réplique pas invaincu de toute façon
tout cela est de ta faute alors tu vas
faire le concours avec moi voilà une
assiette à un automne allemand cela
n'implique pas en mangeant
[Musique]